hi I'm Todd crane --an here for a reason
TV and we're talking with the ACL u--'s
Chris calibrates about civil liberties
issues that have been raised by new
proposals for comprehensive immigration
reform so the ACLU is particularly
concerned with about the expansion of
the e-verify program it's a government
program that allows employers to
instantly check the status of their
workers I was just wondering what is the
problem in your view with Avera 5 well
there's a couple of problems I mean
first you have to sort of understand
what Eve Arif is it's basically a giant
list of everyone who's supposed to be
authorized to work in the United States
which means a giant list of everyone in
the United States legally well that
creates a couple of major issues the
first is what happens if your if the
list is messed up in some way if you're
wrong if your information is wrong in
the list well that's gonna prevent you
from working or at least mean that you
have to go to the government and get
your information fixed before you can
work you verify has become increasingly
accurate they're talking about 99%
accuracy which sounds great until you
realize that there's a hundred and fifty
million American workers which a 1%
error rate means 1.5 million workers
will have some kind of error that needs
to be fixed that's a huge problem I mean
we really feel like the government
shouldn't be standing between a worker
and a new job all right well
unfortunately a tentative
non-confirmation was returned it appears
the information I entered doesn't match
with the Social Security
Administration's information I've
printed out your TNC notice i I don't
understand so if I can do a basically a
check about whether you're authorized to
be in the United States you can think of
lots of other uses for that system
besides employment like voting or travel
renting a house you can sort of see how
an e-verify system a system that is
essentially a giant cardless national ID
system
could be you know I could have an
e-verify or a police officer kind of an
e-verify app on his phone and stop you
on the street because you've you know
you don't look right to him hit the
e-verify app and say you know sir I'm
gonna need your social security number
and your name in order to make sure
you're right in the e-verify system and
imagine if the e-verify system becomes
this sort of de facto check you have to
be right with the verify in order to
avoid being accosted by a police officer
potentially even taken down to the
station but we already have to show
social security card everywhere we go
right you know in some ways social
security of course is a great example
right it started at this not for
identification purposes at all that's
it's said that on the original social
security card that it wasn't to be used
for identification well here we have it
you know seven years later it's used
constantly for identification it's used
for all sorts of things I think the
difference is that people ask you for
your social security cards they want to
use it as an identifier and if you don't
have it sometimes you'll get sort of a
hard time oftentimes merchants or other
people sort of refine and though because
they want to sell you the service or the
good but if there's an outside
quote-unquote objective source like a
database that's saying oh you're not you
know we don't have you in the database
then that's that's different
that's legal gives the officer or the
person who's making a decision about you
the employer a reason to say oh I'm
sorry we can't give you this job we
can't you know I'm sorry I'm gonna have
to take you down to the station for
further questioning so and that's
exactly what we're gonna see I mean if
you verify becomes mandatory the result
will be that you will essentially have
to get cleared with a government right
to work list before you can start a job
and that's a huge change should the
government be in the business of
requiring businesses to verify its
workers in the first place is that the
root of the problem ultimately you know
and that's a great question
I mean why why would we say that that
businesses should be enforcing
immigration law I mean if you stop and
just think about it in that context
that's very strange I mean we don't ask
employers to go out and
you know enforce the drug laws you know
employers are not police officers except
in this one context where we suddenly
want them to be law enforcement agents
who are you know who are going to
essentially police their workforces
you've referenced Bill Keller's
arguments in new york times which i
thought were really interesting and but
one of the points he makes which i have
to concede has some truth to it at least
for me is that you know we live in a new
era of like facebook and social
networking and i was just thinking you
know people have a different attitude
towards privacy in the 21st century than
they did certainly when i was growing up
i'm wondering does that lend any
credence to to the idea of a national ID
like that well you know what's
interesting i think that you're
absolutely right people do have a
different idea of privacy now than they
might have twenty or thirty years ago
you know privacy used to maybe mean
secrecy nobody knows about it but
privacy today is still very relevant
just slightly different what for most
people today privacy is really about
control it's really about deciding who
sees my information what's done with it
I may be posting it on Facebook but I
have my control set so that only my
friends are seeing this information I
have an expectation that I'm sharing it
with particular people well a national
ID really just changes that it turns it
on its head now the control is with the
government they decide what's going to
happen with your information what
they're going to do with it and make
decisions about your life based on their
information that's really the polar
opposite of me deciding what I'm going
to tweet out or what I'm going to share
on Facebook so what do you propose as a
better solution a better reform that
would allow workers and employers to get
together without having to have all of
these issues with a verification and
enforcement you know the first thing I
think we need to recognize is there's 11
million people in this country who are
workers they work hard they may not be
documented they may not be legal workers
but they're contributing to the American
workforce they're paying taxes and if we
say if we legalize those people as many
Congress have suggested is appropriate
and the ACLU agrees that deals with a
lot of the problem right then we don't
we're not trying to
we doubt because all those workers are
legal and then what we need to do is
make a concerted effort to enforce the
existing laws we have for employment
there will be no incentive to hire an
undocumented worker if you still have to
pay wage and hour laws if you still have
to provide those individuals with
appropriate benefits in other words a
lot of the lure of illegal immigration
comes because it allows employers to
skirt existing labor laws so if we stop
that I think we stop a lot of the real
problem No thank you very much on that
show
that's ACL u--'s Chris Calabrese
I'm Todd crane in for TV thank you very
much thanks a lot good to talk to you
pleasure